this guy's gonna end his career at some
point with the Dallas Mavericks he's
Dirk Nowitzki entering his 21st season
with the Mavs Dirk good morning how are
you yeah I know I know but the circus is
back in town so I'm glad it's still one
of my favorite stories I even say that
to Cuban all the time I said man when
Dirk walked into practice that day and
he saw me shooting around and then you
said the circus is in town and then and
then Cuban goes yeah he does that when
anybody's in there shooting around who's
not supposed to be shooting around
personal against you but he kind of took
it personal over left yeah you know that
was kind of the saying at the time or
like stick a tent over this place it's a
search of stuff I mean there's always if
you're an NBA franchise every day
there's something you don't expect so
it's it's always that's something me and
Ashlee always used to say and so of
course when you play horse down there
with with little Avery that that was one
of the things that came out and it stuck
with you yeah yeah do you hold a grudge
like do you have anything that you've
held on to basketball might really I
mean there are certain things that gets
you around up a little bit during the
game but I think usually after the game
that's that's forgotten and then on the
next one I mean as you know there's just
so many games coming each weekend you
know it's kind of hard to really pick
out one game but there's obviously big
games where you feel a little more juice
steps and then just a regular Tuesday
night game somewhere on the road but you
know I don't really hold grudges or you
have a rivalry player wise I mean when
we were when we were just starting to
get really good it was
we saw Sacramento Kings every year in
the playoffs you know what in the old
arena there with the cowbells behind
with Asia and Webber and divas that what
we thought of at least three four times
in the playoffs that was awesome then
obviously the the Spurs are so close to
us here and they always kind of beat up
on us and then in O six we finally came
through and beat him there in Game seven
so
those were those were some fun memories
there off of teams we saw in the
playoffs really almost every year and
those were those were to go all days for
us but since then you know we've been
struggling a bit we haven't really been
a playoff team so it's kind of hard to
say where we got a rivalry with if you
can make playoffs how does the
conversation go with you and your wife
when you decide that you're gonna come
back for your 21st season she knew it
you know she knows it still without what
I love to do you know it's an endless
summer I try to be obviously here for
the family we got three little kids now
so you know I try to spend as much time
as I can because obviously in you know
in a winner or junus season and a family
does have to have to sacrifice a lot but
she knows you know once once my career
is over which will be fairly soon then
you know I got all the time in the world
and we're gonna travel some and enjoy
some stuff that I wasn't able to do
during my playing career with the kids
like go skiing and just fun stuff like
that is we're gonna do and enjoy each
other's company for for the rest of my
life but as of now I still want to play
at a high level and that means a lot of
working out and getting ready for for
the new season what did Steve Nash guy
you know he's been out for a while and I
know that you know he had to retire
because of his back among other things
but but what's nash say about you coming
back for another season he likes it we
are just texted about something actually
a more cubans 260 next week so he said
he's having a big bash so we're we were
texting about that for a bit but no he's
he's obviously excited for me and we
talked a little bit about retirement
already there's a a couple of my friends
have retired a few years ago like Finlay
Nash I talked to Mike Modano about it
just you know about retirement what's
what's coming in and and they all say
hey the first year or two
is tough you know you're gonna miss it
you're gonna miss everything about the
locker room and the competition and it's
I think that's normal you know you just
you just try to prepare already now too
for some stuff that you got going that
once you're out that you stay busy a bit
and obviously enjoy the family but he
said whatever you do you know the first
year once the summer is fine and in
September October rolls around he was
supposed to go to camp and there's just
nothing coming that's that's got to be
extremely strange what do you buy Cuban
for his 60th birthday yeah you know we
all know he's not really a materialistic
kind of guy you know he walks around
with his old jeans it is mfsl shirt and
his old Skechers or whatever he's
wearing there and you know he just he
doesn't really you know love buying
things for himself and he's just doesn't
it's not how he rolls so it's I have no
idea I'm still still thinking about it
so maybe somebody else has some some
input but usually my wife has pretty
good ideas but on this one where it kind
of comes on it how about just some more
tight t-shirts you know I think that
yeah tight t-shirt you know what he
rolls there's a lot of sleeveless shirts
you know that kind of told him hey you
turn it 60 times
I'm not sure maybe we'll go sleeveless
shirt he's Dirk Nowitzki the Mavs
forward going into his 21st season with
the Mavs do you know where you stand on
the all-time scoring list about to be
seven fortunately the locker room is
ruthless so you know you guys check your
clearance at the door every day you
never get killed about shoes and outfit
and this and that so the guy's already
been calling me seven for the last year
obviously saw how fast the ball is
coming but I'm holding on
strong but no it's it's obviously you
know when I started 20 years ago I've
never was taught I'd be up there with so
many greatest that ever played this game
so it's it's still humbling and you know
obviously an honor to be the mention
with some of the greatest in the game so
it's that's just awesome what did you
think of LeBron going to the Lakers I
didn't see that coming actually but you
know it's great for the Lakers you know
they want to build another another
dynasty to add a few down years and you
know did you know that when the Broncos
there it's gonna be destination again
for all the free agents and so it's
gonna be great for the league you know
it's always great in the league when the
Lakers and the Knicks are great Boston
you know those are those old-school
teams when they're great usually it's
great for the league so it's gonna be
fun but the West is something's stacked
that's why I thought you might stay the
East but I mean the West is super super
loaded every night it's gonna be a going
to be fun to compete Kevin Durant I
don't know if he if he's overly
sensitive do you follow any of his stuff
on social media with Kevin Durant he's
not afraid to engage yeah I don't follow
him on Twitter but obviously it's tough
not to see what's going on and I just
think overall in general I don't know
why why you wouldn't get engaged with
with fans talking trash I mean there's I
like you having actually fun with it you
know I mean I get I get hit up on
Twitter every now and then my mentions
hey you old you know go away retire or
something like that to me it's fun
you know it's you're not supposed to be
sensitive about it that's that's how I
look at it and I'm not sure why why
Katie feels the need as a response to
some of those stuff because I mean it's
just Twitter it's just such a place
where for tough guys and a lot of hate
and you know I just I take it with a
weather with a smile on my face you know
you can you can take yourself too
seriously yeah it's you know I know you
had fun well you were trying to have fun
when Germany got knocked out of the
World Cup I'm just saying you kind of
had fun a little bit with it that you
expressed your feelings it was gonna
take you a little while I think to
respond after how painful was that yeah
that was tough I mean I feel like you
know the run of the we want four years
ago and then I think when still on the
top as we all know all the all the
athletes to stay on top is really really
hard and and I think where the guys are
and some of the players some retired
some you know where the world champs
called that for four years and then I
think I don't think we had that edge I
don't think we we played that well even
coming into the tournament the last
couple of games I think we even lost
Austria at home two weeks before the
tournament so it's just we weren't we
weren't quite on it and everybody still
say hey we're usually a tournament team
once the tournament starts well well
turn it around and then they just do
just wasn't there just wasn't there
couldn't score enough goals so it was I
was unfortunate it's unfortunate but to
me it was still a fun World Cup to watch
I mean there were some great surprises
and great teams loved watching Croatia I
mean every country or what whatever 12
million people or something anything
like four million really I'm not even
sure but just amazing amazing stories
and fun to watch if your kids are good
at soccer do do we get them as Americans
or does Germany get them you know
honestly they're already all so tall I'd
like like daddy it was tough for me to
play soccer I mean everybody kicks
around a little bit growing up but you
know I was just not very good they
always say hey Derrick you want to play
goal today I think that was that was a
hint like hey lurch together we can need
you unknown so on the pitch but you know
I say I think they're gonna be better
than other things they already started
play tennis a little bit which which is
my number one sport which I love the
play growing up and so we put him in
some tennis and obviously some
basketball later on but were you a Boris
Becker fan Oh Boris and Steffi Graf you
kidding me I mean they were like they
were heroes growing up in Germany and
then Michael station one
when one year two so yeah we had a
couple great tennis tennis guys they are
a great generation therefore for a while
it was fun to watch have you met them
Becker and stuffy I met I met Boris
Newman sometimes being the Wimbledon a
couple of times because I was like I
said I'm a huge tennis fan and so I met
I met Federer Amit met Boris I met a
bunch of people in the tennis world uh
really loved that I have not made Steffi
yet have her poster up on your wall did
you Rona I'm sure you know at that point
when I was like 12 13 I was already a
huge NBA fan so I think of a MBA
dominant room picture wise but I might
have snuck a one or two tennis pictures
in there if I said you could be an
all-time great obviously basketball but
soccer if you if you or tennis so let's
say you had to do over you already know
what you already know your NBA career
but I have magic dust I can sprinkle on
and you can be a Boris Becker type or
you can be pick out somebody in soccer
that you can be what would you choose in
as your sport that's I mean I love hoops
I love everything about it because
that's why I stuck with it when I was
like 13 you know just every day you can
learn something new and if you watch a
game like oh man that's cool I want to
learn how to do that I mean there's just
so many possibilities and in that sport
that uh that I loved and it also came
obviously easy to me because I was
always tall but I mean soccer is such a
noble sport you know it's it is amazing
maybe if you're a soccer star you know
you you've ever sleeve made it anywhere
in the world but the u.s. but I don't
know that's that's a tough call but I
guess I would do it again the way I did
are you down as cowboy fan you know I
didn't grow up with with baseball or
all so when I got here I got introduced
with obviously the Rangers and the
cowboy so it's kind of easy for me to
root for for the local teams because I
didn't grow up having to him so I had it
easier than when other guys could come
here and they obviously grew up watching
other teams and then it kind of makes
them seem like they're not loyal to
their to the to the community here or
whatever that wasn't the case for me I
never grew up watching football or
baseball so it made sense for me to just
roll through for the local team so it
was easy it's been it's been a heck of a
ride for for those franchises and
hopefully on the upward and bringing
some championships back soon here to the
Big B have you what do you think of
Lucca Don check right after the dress
was ruined mainly for the press
conference and I was there I met him
seems like a great kid have never seen
him play live a full game obviously have
seen some highlights but you know the
sky's the limit he's only 19 he's got an
illegal court vision already he could
score he can pass he's big enough he's
actually legit six nine listed next on
mmm he can make plays off the bounce and
I think he just he's got a great
basketball IQ you know the question is
that the one two or whatever he's going
to play is he quick enough can he keep
up with some of the athletes we have in
our league but I think he's gonna be
fine he's smart and he'll learn he's
eager to learn he's worked hard so I
think he'll be a great pick up for us
obviously with the andre role into the
rim that's gonna hopefully open up some
stuff for us so I think we're gonna be
better than them we were last year
obviously and hopefully we can we can
bring maybe some playoff basketball back
to Dallas they'll be fun do you have a
posterized dunk you know I was I was
thinking about this when we're gonna
have you on I was like I wonder if Dirk
has a signature dunk where you look back
you show the kids like look at dad
throwing down do you have one I think I
got posterized more than hi I was here
the posterizing I was just never known
for
for my explosiveness of my hops at the
rim but there is one that every time we
get you know it's hard for me to come in
after a game like we practice at 10:00
10:30 in the morning after a game I look
so stiff and obviously the guys just
absolutely kill me so so then after like
once in a while I feel the urge to pull
up YouTube and at least sort of a couple
clips that I was able to move because
some of these young guys they don't know
they don't know they don't know me when
I was 20 21 so I'll pull up a few things
they hey better check and check me too I
do I do hit him with that once in a
while there's one Don Cal always a
member of in Seattle it might have been
my second or third year I caught the
ball on the baseline of drove middle and
I think I've even my eyes closed and I
just went up and don't one so that's
that was that's that's the clave of Fame
I got I got you dunking on Weber and
devant you're going baseline you
remember that yeah I do remember that
one that was a little little later I
think I was yeah I was already like 24
25 when but yeah that was a good one
baseline but the one lookup the one in
Seattle and your producers gonna hook
you up with that one but that one other
was my favorite now I love that we're
firing up the girls meet Friday if we
were gonna have German food if you were
barbecuing what would you recommend well
if you're Germany you got to have your
bratwurst two minutes that's a
no-brainer a bratwurst maybe uh you know
a little steak usually it's when we do
steaks in Germany it's more pork so it's
pork steak
what kind of beer we have it I mean you
know usually in Germany all little towns
have their own brewery so even my
hometown has has a worse burger Hofbrau
is the local brewery and my dad probably
kept that thing in business myself for
the last 15 years I didn't love it much
it's a little bitter form
I'm not really that much of a beer guy
but usually you just go it you can order
the the local beer is usually in good
shape who retires first you or Vince
Carter oh man
actually we when I saw him this year
Zack
we both said hey us they we're gonna do
one more so it's looking like we might
retire together but we'll see we'll see
how this year goes I'll see how the body
feels you know I had surgery and uh you
know April right after the season on my
ankle two little clean-out jobs so as
you would expect that 40 it's healing a
little slow so we'll see how this season
goes but you know hopefully maybe it'll
be fun to retire together we came in
together he we played together is a
great dude we had had a lot of fun so
how that would be actually a fun little
thing well congrats and hopefully the
the wife and kids enjoy this upcoming
season certainly the Mavs fans as well
but good to talk to you again Dirk all
right that's Dirk Nowitzki these circus
is in town please phone down for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]